we talk so much about inclusion and
nobody
has ever talked about this before and
around me so i'm just curious like troy
daniel y'all like what kind of like
movie would you love to do like what
kind of movies would you love to see now
like
this is like more introduced to pop
culture now and i feel like hearing
a story that maybe we've heard before
but from a different vantage point is so
important
well i mean we have so many stories we
have so many more stories about deaf
culture to tell we really can and we can
play any character and i would love to
see
more deaf superheroes and maybe adding
more characters like a deaf character in
star wars i know he's in the middle
the mandalorian it's amazing he's the
first deaf person on star wars so it's a
huge honor and i applaud him
there's so many things we have
the deaf community has so a rich history
of storytelling
and so
i would like to just plant the seed and
share these stories um there were
historical stories in slavery times
there was there's a lot of deaf history
and so we can begin to pick those
carrots and bring them forward and so i
really want to change everyone's
perspective and show everyone what deaf
people went through because many folks
don't understand and thanks to coda it
speaks for itself and it's increasing
awareness of the deaf community and
we're bridging two worlds the hearing
and the deaf world for which for so long
were separate and so we focused on one
side we focused on the other and where
is the center the center is the coda and
so amelia was the center of our story
that pulled both of these communities
together
[Music]
you